hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the 2020 Tata Steel masters
edition it's a virus levert immune
versus Fabiana Caruana Fabiano corona
already won the tournament since he's a
half a point in the lead-up went and
having lead ahead of Magnus Carlsen
but still you you always want to play
that last game of the tournament well so
let's see how this goes and also
congratulations to Spain for winning the
world handball championship I don't
really watch handle but I did watch the
finals and it was quite the game so
congratulations on that and also I would
just like to say that the video team
from the Greinke chess classic sent me a
trailer for their upcoming a green cape
2020 so if you want to check it out it
will be the link the first thing you
will see in the description below it's
about one minute long so feel free to
check it out that being said let's check
out the game artemyev opens with knife
to f3
so the reti opening is on the board we
have d5 by fabien now g3 the Kings
Indian attack
we have Knight to d7 and now see for the
Fabi captures the captaincy for Queen a4
going back after the pawn and now a6
preparing b5 which would cement that
pawn on c4 so of course Artemyev
captures it and b5 pushing the Queen
back we have Queen to c2 and the now
Bishop the b7 Bishop the g2 Artemyev
continuous development Knight G to f6
and now castles with east sex by far be
preparing to develop the dark square
bishop and the d3 artemyev does the same
we rush up the e7 and now a 4 of course
you want to attack this a nice expansion
Fabi has on the Queen side and now c5 so
we have first before capturing here a
knight the c3 we have Queen to b6 by
Fabi developing and now a captures on b5
which shows that Artemia wants to trade
rooks along the a5 we have Brooke
characters to need Bishop captures and
now Bishop to g5 we have castles by Fabi
and now look back well the other look
comes to a 1 we have h6 asking Artemia
what do you want to do with the bishop
put it back or a trade for the night
here Artemyev captures with Bishop
captures on f6 and now this position has
been reached before in 2017 between
surrogate matsuhiko and Illya and ethnic
where Queen to b3 was played and Queen
to b3 is actually one of the engines top
recommendations so it's safe to say safe
to assume actually that artemyev is no
longer in book so he goes Knight the d2
offers a trade of light squared
the shops with the shopkeepers and g2
King captures and now rook the c8 so
here by playing rock to c8 Fabi says
that he's maybe interested in playing c4
but here we have Queen to b3 by artemiev
preventing that are showing that from
the game we mentioned in 2017 Queen to
b3 a well b3 is actually a good square
for the Queen because now Fabi has the
option of pushing c4 but c4 is basically
a draw for because after this c4 move
you would see D captures in c4 Queen to
c6 width check now after the king moves
king g1 now you capture on c4 attack the
Queen Queen a4 offer a queen trade Queen
b7 attack the the b2 pawn and now Knight
captures on c4 and now after Knight b6
you attack the Queen and the Knight
captures captures you get this position
where white is up upon but white will
not be able to keep the pawn there's the
threat of Queen captures and b2 and also
the threat of just Bishop characters
follows by rook captures pawn so you
cannot really cover both threats so
Fabi could go for c4 if he's interested
which is like I said I draw off her and
he already won the tournament it doesn't
really matter to him if he draws this
game and he has the black pieces against
artemyev which is not not a bad deal but
Bobby decides he wants to play on which
which is why he moves the rogue back to
be 8 so if he wanted to play rock debate
he could've done so right away but here
he just says I'm not just yet convinced
that that we're gonna draw this game so
night c2 e for putting pressure on the
bishop and the c5 pawn Fabi goes back
Bishop e7 nicely providing more more
defense to the c5 point and now King g1
the King will be much safer here
you don't have to constantly check out
for any any checks along the light
square diagonal after the knife from e4
moves and now F 5 by Fabi yes the DS
exponent is somewhat weak now but Bobby
decides that that it's okay so tonight
back to c3 and now Knight to e5 an
excellent square for the knight if he
can keep it there and here h3 taking
away the g4 square from fob is night
with h5 and now Knight to f3 offering a
trade of knights with Knight captures in
now he captures on f3 getting this set
up that well jus in June had against the
garage q now if you've checked out the
final game of the Rapids
we had Bishop to f6 by Fabi and now rook
to e1 trying to pile up on the weekly
six pawn but here King to f7 for besides
that this is okay there's no way to
exploit to this pin and also while
watching the the coverage in chess 24
young Gustav son mentioned briefly that
Fabi actually plays plants versus
zombies now I don't know if this is true
but if that is so I I commend him that
is an excellent game only part one I did
not enjoy part two but their plants vs.
zombies really really an awesome game
but they are king to have seven by Fabi
and now Knight to e2 would Knight to e2
Artemyev tries to bring yet a third
attacker to the e6 pawn so 92 and here
Fabi goes g5 he says and no you don't h4
was also a possibility here trying to
create some weaknesses on the Kings side
but artemyev is a very long time and
Fabi says okay g5 just takes away DF
Foursquare from from your knight and you
have 40 14 minutes on the clock I have
more than half an hour and it's only
moved 27 so you still need to make 13
more moves to reach time control so
artemiev goes on g4 so what do you do
here H captures on g4 we have H captain
g4 f captors in g4 f captors in g4 and
now Queen to d6 here Fabi centralized
this is Queen and he wants to bring the
rook over to HH to go after Queen to h2
if he can do that it should be should be
a very nice position for him so my g3
Barthe me of blocking
diagonal and also preparing to bring the
knight over to e4 which will be an
excellent square for him Queen the d5
now Fabi offers a queen trade if if
artemiev obliges this will fix Fabrice
pawn structure resulting in him having
only two point islands whereas our
teammate will have three pilots and
these are well three very dangerous
gentlemen I might call them gentlemen
from now on since you guys enjoy it so
much but we'll see so Queen to d5
artemiev does not want to trade Queen's
Queen back to sea to end the now Bishop
to d4 nicely pinning the F pawn which
comes in handy in a lot of lines and
also still just preparing rook to a
trait which will put pressure on the h1
square so the knight will not be able to
move but Queen to e2 now and here we
have rook to h8 as planned and now
Knight to e4 uh if you don't move the
Knight to e4 your knight will not be
able to move to some other squares and
also here is just an excellent square
for the knight since Bobby does not have
a deep on the kicker way Bobby does not
have an F pawn to kick it away and he
doesn't have well sorry that was a
glitch if he doesn't have a light square
bishop so the knight can stay there for
as long as and as long as he wants we
have Queen back the e5 by Fabi going
after Queen to h2 now and here Queen to
f3 check the only good idea for artemyev
King to g7 and here Artemyev has only
one and a half minute on the clock
whereas Fabi has 22 minutes and it's
only moved thirty five so five more
moves for our team if to reach time
control and here it's a very interesting
position you can even pause the video
and try to find a move for our team if
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
to find a usable move for our timing of
your congratulations you are an
excellent spotter of moves under immense
pressure and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show Artem I've played
b3 here which just gets the pawn out of
harm's way but there is also the rook to
eat to move and this seems to be the way
to go as it clears the
for the team to escape if needed but
also it provides protection to the beat
upon not in a way that you can't capture
it the point is if you capture the point
here then the point is you play nice the
g3 which prevents the Queen from
reaching h2 but also opens up an attack
against the black Queen and now after
you move the Queen let's say Queen f6
now you play Queen f7 check not tonight
H 5 9 h5 seems reasonable because it
Forks the king and the Queen but here
black would actually just give up the
rook it's not a problem and after
characters captures now you can just
capture the rook G captures an H five
and after Bishop c3 still fairly draw
since it's four points to three yes you
do have a look against the bishop but
this spawn will easily fall so it's it's
actually four points against two black
will be able to draw this game so
basically the point is after this if you
go for this Bishop captures on b2 line
you go 93 and then now you go
Queen f6 like we said offering it ready
but now Queen b7 not not Knight h5 this
comes with check King moves and now you
go Queen to c6 threatening rook captures
here not much you can do here with black
you cannot defend since the Queen covers
that and well there there is not much
you can do you could try something like
this but then you no longer guard the
bishop here so let's say just queen
efore check and next move your you can
just pick up the the bishop so that's a
one of the things that can happen so
after Luke to e2 capturing here and not
an option you could go for Queen H to
check but then just King f1 and now how
do you continue the attack rook f8
attacks the Queen but now Queen g2 and
after Queen to f4
now you go nice - D - and now you
exposed the attack towards the d6 pawn
and with the the Queen constantly eyeing
b7 it is a sufficient means to hold this
so after this Queen King g7 look to e2
definitely an option but under really
immense time pressure
finding such moves there definitely not
an option so b3 birthday me of not
allowing captures and now comes rope the
FN by Fabi Queen 2
to check doesn't really do anything it
just runs into pretty much the same
defense only you no longer have a target
on me - so Fabi switches the roof to f8
instead Queen back to e - and then out
comes Queen d5 again in excellent square
for the queen but putting pressure on
the b3 pawn and now again what do you do
here here our team we've played rook to
f1 he wants to play rook F 1 Kings you
to play f3 and says that this holds but
there was also the very interesting King
- h2 line immediately unpinning and if
Queen captures on b3 then you go Queen
d2 and now you might have some problems
regarding the g5 pawn for example if
rook to f4 now you play f3 and well it's
it's a very sturdy setup about the point
is that well you can never capture an f3
because the Queen captures an g5 so now
the rook is pretty much stuck here and
that there's always just a knight
characters and g5 will be an idea so a
lot of good ideas here so look the f1
instead by artemyev make sense since if
you move the knight you you never want
to rope characters or orbital characters
to be an ox and so rook is a nice
defender here kingi sex by Fabi now adds
another defender to the g5 pawn and now
Queen D 1 here Artemyev defends the b3
pawn and now finally Fabi goes for the
break through c4 and ok B captors and c4
we have B captures and now you cannot
capture because of captures so here King
to g2 and this already move 40 so both
players have reached time control with
this move King G - now artemyev prepares
to play f3 but it requires giving up a
pawn so here we have Bishop to e7 by
Fabi also an option was just troop the
foreign after f3 creating a passed pawn
by playing C 3 but Fabi decides against
that he decides for Bishop to e7
and now after f3 you still can't capture
him because the night Hank so f3 this is
a crucial move for for defending but now
C captures on d3 now fabric grabs upon
and also creates a nice pass pawn and
again what do you do here why is the
line we've shown rook to f4 followed by
a sort of rook to f4 the line we've
shown followed by creating a passport by
just pushing it to c3 is preferred by
the engine
with but but it's hard to understand why
of course and it seems like every game
Fabi plays it's like only Fabi is able
to make sense of these insane lines but
ok here artemyev played Quinta a 1 and
it makes sense he guards the df6 square
so if the rook ever moves Queen f6 check
pretty much guarantees a draw at least
and even if the rook leaves the the back
rank then also Queen to H it will be an
idea in in a lot of lines but there was
also the Queen to d2 line we just puts
pressure on the g5 pawn and again it's
now the Queen cannot move you have to
keep an eye on the g5 pawn so that line
paralyzes the rook this line paralyzes
the Queen also an option so now after
rook c2 e rook c8 going for rook to c2
now you block rook c1 and after captures
captures now let's say Bishop e6
you cannot cross the D 2 square so you
have to he'll have help from the bishop
if you can get Bishop to a5 in that
could be handy but King F 1 and now if
you go Bishop to a5 now you have Queen
a1 and now you have problems Queen
threatens Queen f6 but also Quinte trade
so now you can go back the ship d8
guarding this square but now Queen 288
ensures a draw for Artemyev for example
if d2 you just have a perpetual here
there's not much you can do here with
with the pawn and night and guarding all
of these squares so Queen to d2 an
improvement on artemis move our teammate
goes Queen the a1 instead so like we
said that line paralyzes the Queen this
line paralyzes the rook
but now our fabi's queen is free to roam
so Bobby goes Bishop to e3 always this
always remind yes and the bishop of
course of course is under attack this
always reminds me of the old Josh
Waitzkin the square left behind so here
in that line Queen d2 d3 square was
taken now Bishop to e3 by Fabi and okay
the best of also covers D 2 square so
you can put upon 2 B 2 so rook to d1 by
artemiev and now as the Queen can move
Queen to c4 the idea is Queen to see for
Czech so artemyev blocks he wants to
trade Queens but Bobby says no no way
quinta a to check and now if you move
the King if you go anywhere along the H
file just rotate rate is enough but if
you
walking to f1 then Quinta e 2 is mate so
our team it has to block nights the d2
but now Queen to c2 and now it's very
hard to find a move for a team if for
example if you trade Queens it's just
lost you either lose the rook or remove
the rook and you lose the night so here
our team we've played Queen to e5 but
now comes Bishop captures and v2 Fabi
just grabs grabs a clean piece and he of
course had to calculate that this does
not result in a perpetual so Queen
captures on e6 was played King g7 Queen
e7 check rook F 725 check in back to f8
Queen to be a twit check King East 7 you
have to go for for a nice walk with the
King Queen e5 check King d8 we have
Queen to be a twit check now King d7
Quinta b7 check and now King d6 we have
Queen b6 check Kingdom a 5 and the Queen
to b5 check we have king d4 and now
Queen to b6 again with check kink the c4
and the Queen b6 check and Bobby just
hides the king king c3 so now you don't
really gain anything if you capture if
you capture it just Bishop f4 opens up a
discovery if you go down the board and
Queen captures rook with check if you go
here it's just queen h2 mate so after
king c3 artemyev has no choice he has to
continue checking 25 check we have King
to b3 Queen d5 check King to b2 and the
now Queen to b5 check
and now finally Bishop the B for
blocking check but also opening up a
discover to check so king g3 but now
it's 5:00 Eastern twin capture Sun d1 we
have Queen captures on b4 with check and
Queen b3 so of course our team if cannot
trade he's done a full full rook so
Queen d2 check King Tubby one and now
Quinta II one check with King to c2
Queen of to check birthday me and
finally d2 and it was in this position
that Vladislav Artemia resigned the game
as he is down the rook and once once the
Queen gets into the game doesn't really
matter how you can do something like
let's say here and go to e1 or well you
just bring the rook into the game there
are a lot of ways you can win this white
is wet it's pretty much getting made it
very quickly so of course our team you
have resigned
the game here so very impressive game
bye-bye car won a very impressive
tournament by Caruana
he could have just drawn the game at
will here again start Amy with the black
pieces which like I say it's not a bad
deal but for a 2800 player like Fabi who
is also a former butcher championship
challenger that is simply out of the
question so he wins this game also and
just so we don't forget it here are the
standings after after 13 rounds of the
2020 Tata Steel masters edition Fabi
wins the tournament with two full points
ahead of Magnus Carlsen and this is an
immense feet because Magnus did not have
a bad tournament he didn't lose a single
game he just drew a lot of games so
Carlson had three wins and all the other
games were drawn whereas Fabi had seven
wins and six games run so more wins than
draws that's that's just insane but yeah
you can see that fabi's rating
performance is 20 945 which was just
insane and Magnus says is only twenty
eight hundred and eighteen yes for
Magnus that is and only twenty eight
hundred and eighteen because his rating
is twenty eight hundred and seventy two
so he actually loses rating if he only
performs at twenty eight hundred and
eighteen yeah but yeah that that's what
it's like when you're Magnus so really
impressive stuff by Fabi two full points
ahead of Magnus ten of 13 then Magnus in
second place with eight out of 13
followed by Wesley in third with seven
and a half then Jordan went forest with
seven Daniel Lugo with seven with six
and a half we have initially Vishwanath
on Anand young Christophe Duda our eyes
of Arusha with six and a half
we have Jeffrey Sheehan Vladislav our
teammate with six Nikita B to go with
five young he would four and a half and
vladislav Korolev in last place the he
not the greatest of tournaments but you
know you live and you learn and also III
think well I've read that I still didn't
finish watching the term but in the
challengers section David Anthony Hara
want the challengers edition so he will
be participating in the Masters edition
next year like we did this year as he
won the challengers edition alas sir so
we'll see how key Haro will do
next year so really impressive stuff by
Fabia definitely he's definitely one of
the favorites in the in the candidates
tournament I'm also very much interested
in could you who do you have as favorite
in the candidates turn and do you see
Fabi as taking it again do you see ding
ding said that he will not be playing
any tournaments until the candidates
tournament in April and he's just
training you know non-stop for further
candidates tournament you know probably
at you know 3 300 times the gravity yeah
you know he's just gonna be a monster at
the candidates tournament and also
there's there's team or a job of who who
just I don't know where shows up and
wins tournaments it's just it's just
gonna be really awesome and it will be
very interesting to see how young Alec
Cinco will do at the candidates as well
so yeah I'm very much interested in your
opinion what do you have at the
candidates don't forget to check out the
link in the description below it will be
it's a trailer one minute long turd
growing it just classic do check it out
I would like to thank Diego Romero I
mean he'll be soaked or Michael be
soaked John che William McCain and
Nathan Baker Nathan Baker with his
contribution becomes the top contributor
to the channel some cook congratulations
on that sir so yeah that's that's pretty
much it I do hope you enjoyed this game
I do hope you enjoyed the coverage of
this tournament as usual you can check
to my previous video serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the well now
we don't have the coverage of anything
but I will have to check out some of the
games from the Gibraltar chess festival
and we are basically continuing the
Morphy saga so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day